these kitchens are not a disaster this
is not this is not cooking
uh oh my god
you call this rat tattoo
hi i'm oscar isaac and i'm ethan hawk
and this is first impressions for lad
bible you wanna go first okay i'll go
first
um
um how do you like them apples
i got a number
how do you like them apples oh oh um
you like apples matt damon
[Applause]
that was well done good this is like
charades at christmas
okay um i'm not gonna do this and come
off you can do it she sings a great
christmas song all i want for chris
um oh uh um
she's got a great christmas song
and she looks cute in the outfit but you
have to do it
yeah but i can't remember how it goes
and i don't know any of her other music
i have to pass i'm passing them mariah
carey yes
that was a giveaway okay all right
these kitchens are not a disaster this
is not this is not cooking
uh oh my god
you call this rat tattoo
i'm definitely is this from a cooking
show or something yeah
but i don't know
freaked out all the time no i don't know
and he does i just know that it is a
cooking show
okay i would have never gotten ten
thousand years i wouldn't have gotten
there
uh
all right um
[Music]
i like to do any movie because i just
any movie that suits me i don't you know
i like to get paid a lot of money and uh
richard harris turkey and um no i'm
gonna teach acting and it's not about
what you're saying it's about what you
don't blink when the camera's looking at
you and uh uh oh
will you ever forgive me for being so
bloody stupid peachy and so bleeding
arrogant
okay um
no it's really hard it's really hard
because um
no not richard harris
the opposite of richard harris but the
same if they're bickering at a bar cause
you drink too much and you don't take
acting seriously which is like to hell
with you mate you take yourself too
seriously no you do it for the money and
i do it for the love oh michael k
jesus
i just failed in that one okay um um
another button
bats heads off of bat
i am iron man
uh oh we're talking about ozzy osbourne
yeah all right i knew i was like wait i
was like wow all right ozzie okay
oh
okay
all right
mads stop doing that uh eugene what are
you doing over there i'm a dad dad
uh ask me yeah you you oh all right oh
wow okay
all right i didn't know great job okay
got it nailed it okay all right
oh yeah i mean i can do this
um i don't
like ryan reynolds at all
absolutely
hello there i'm ryan reynolds hi there
i'm jody coma and this is first
impressions or lad bible
yes
oh